this is a production of cornell
university
great thank you
uh yeah so as you mentioned i'm brandon
i am a
phd student in the latest smart lab and
i'm actually in geneva and some of you
were talking a little bit today about um
some of the work i've been doing on
monitious willows
all right so uh in the smart lab we work
on troubles which are the section matrix
in the genomics
and these are many uses but we're
primarily
interested in them for a bio energy
usage so
they're grown in a short rotation
compass
um setting so identity planting setting
and they're harvested every three years
and wood chips can then be
burned to generate heat or also used as
a feed stock for biofuel
so i specifically work on the species
settings for courier as a model system
for the strongholds now this as i
mentioned it's dioecious it has a zw sex
termination system which means that
males are z z and females are zw so w is
only inherited through the female line
and then it has about a two to three
generations so here on the on the left
uh these are the female patterns
and it's also a close relative of the
populars which are another important
biomass crop in north america
so
as i mentioned this is a diocese crop
but we do have a single formal obsession
that is actually monitious uh named
94003
uh so here's a picture of it i don't
know if you can see it but
it has male and female flowers on the
same packet so captains are mixed and
have varying amounts of nails from the
flowers so one of the first things we
wanted to do is characterize how does
this monitor sort of vary across
environments and can we get plants that
are all male or are all females that are
otherwise monitors
so we had 9403 already replicated across
353 different environments through a
previous diversity study
so
they were in randomized block designs in
geneva new york at claro in portland new
york and then at west virginia
university in warmingtown
and so i looked at uh
flowering in the field and measuring
percent maleness so basically how much
of the percentage of each captain is
male
relative to female and for the geneva
um
plants we actually took a subset and
forced them two months early in the
greenhouse to see if that changed for 70
hours
um so what we found is that you know
doing that bringing them early in the
greenhouse that did not affect the uh
the percentiles however uh we were able
to model it uh so
the percentiles of
of cap and i um on shoot j
in block a and field l
so we modeled the
the shoot and then the plot the shoot
was implied as random effects and then
the field that the that it was in as a
fixed effect and we found that all these
had a significant effect on the percent
notice so this indicates that there are
both macro environment and micro
environment effects
that are are sort of influencing how
many male or female fibers there are on
on a given factor
and so this dot spot here
this this shows
concern
launched for the greenhouse these are
gina field of morgantown field in
portland field and the gold are when we
measure percent illness by captain
and the red are women
illness by the whole shoot and now if
you'll notice there's not a lot of
difference in the means between uh when
we look at the whole shoe or when we
look at an individual calculator
but we do see pretty substantial
differences between sites notably uh
those thrones knew that were much
had much higher percentage female than
those are growing important or
morgantown also of interest if you'll
notice the range on these we found
entire catkins and indeed entire shoots
that were all male or all female so if
you look at a plant and maybe only has
one shoe of catkins uh they might all be
male and you might misidentify a
monitor's plant as male and that would
be really important moving forward
so i mentioned we have 9403 so in 2015
the smart lab decided to attempt to self
this uh to generate an s1 family uh and
part of this was both for genetic
mappiness and also to
try to uh uncover the the genetic basis
for malicious so
what's our issue is that you know this
we were able to generate an s1 family of
over 400 progeny that were viable which
that alone is pretty interesting because
this is
the species is an obligate outcrosser
because it's diocese but we were able to
get
pretty healthy um family
so we have four years out of flowering
data from this family uh indicated here
uh and from that we found that initially
it looked like the family was segregated
from malicious male and female
but the the ratio was kind of confusing
we weren't really sure how to model this
for any genetic mechanism but when we
looked more closely at the data we
realized that
uh
so so from one nation's plans right you
only need one year of data to confirm
their malicious right if you see a male
and a female flower on the same vacuum
you know it's onicious now for the males
many of these had three or four years of
data consistently supporting that they
were males
but for the females most of these only
had one year of data and then the plants
later died or were very small
so we think that these females are
actually malicious in that we just
didn't have enough data enough packets
to really see any male flowers because
as i mentioned on the previous slide you
can see
all male or all female plants if you
only have a few cabinets
so uh in 2018 we took a single malicious
individual within this family that
started in the engineering has two
families and now we've collected three
years of flowering data on this family
and so once again we see this confirms
it is it appears to be starting from
monitious and now we only see a few
females here and these are likely false
positives they're like ignorance
and so the the
ratio here is about two to one monitors
to male and we plug in gds data on every
individual in this s2 family
uh and then when we look at the sex
determination locus which is on
chromosome 15. that's what's
what's um determining sex and remember
males are as easy females are cw
and when we look at that we saw that
that family appeared to be ceremony for
homozygous um
major allele and heterozygous but no
homozygous minor allele genotypes uh
suggesting that instead of reading for
zw and zzz but there are no w
individuals which right if we're
crossing the zw with a zw that's what we
would expect
and then when we look at the
um the corresponding sexes it the male
seem to correspond to zz and then
malicious to cw
so this um let us hypothesize that
the monitious plants are
are zw genotypically and that there
might be a modification on the w
chromosome that's causing them to be
monitors instead of female
and that model is shown here right so
we're calling this
this modified w w h
so when we sell our macro zero zero
three our malicious plant we get twenty
five percent off uh fifty percent
militia ewh and then the twenty five
percent
what we don't see any of those appearing
carbon
of
in our s2 family when we do the gbs
data
so now to confirm this though i decided
to process when we just plant outcross
it to our reference now in our reference
female genome so we have a reference
reference to milk which we have fully
assembled fully annotated high quality
genomes so that's really facilitates
downstream genetic studies
so when we are across into our our
reference style fish screen which this
is easy we saw about 50 male 1 50
unleashes starvation in that family
which is what we'd expect if if this
malicious mutation is in fact carried on
15 w
um now you'll notice this is a little
bit skewed towards male
uh again we only have two years of data
on this family and uh
i'm almost certain that some of these
males are actually monitious right we
only have one year of data and i think
as we get more years of data they'll get
closer to 50 50. uh but just in two
years a day we already see it's pretty
close to half male half
malicious and really no females
the things that are really interesting
when we process this to our reference
female 94006
so we see about a quarter male or
quarterly malicious but then about half
of the family is actually female which
is way more than we'd expect otherwise
um so we think right so 25 percent of
lcc 25 females ew and 25 percent
malicious eoh
and then we think this other 25 percent
are wh
and that they're female so suggest to us
that okay if a plant is known you should
spread this modified w it's lethal but
it might be that if it has a regular w
and it's modified wh then that is liable
and it's in fact female oh which um so
from that we hypothesize that it's
probably a large indel or inversion on
the 15
w uh such that it it results in a loss
of function and if your homozygous for
that it's diesel
this is just to summarize some of our
hypothesis in our model based on these
families all right so we think the
causal locus for militia is on a
modified 15 w which we're calling 15 wh
um such that these individuals are males
ewh individuals are malicious
uh if you're homozygous for wh that's
lethal by a regular w and a modified w
units
so now moving on to the sort of the
third part of this study is
right so this is all interesting all
right melanie's real is but why do you
really care about having monicious
photos
uh and so
uh one of the original reasons we
created this family was to perform
genetic settings so
right now these plants are only in
single plant plots we're in the process
of scaling them up but it will have a
long generation time so that takes a
while
so even in simplifying plots we've
decided to collect uh data from high
heritability traits so notably uh stab
and leaf dimensions and these are traits
that you know they've been showing you
high heritability and they're also
correlated with biomass
which is important uh for for
willow growth so
um
and we were able to get actually quite a
few qgl's just doing qtl mapping using
single plant plots which is very
promising um so for most of the traits
so i only have three shown here but we
could believe area with leaf shaped but
all these leaf dimension traits are
pretty correlated as one would expect
and actually get very similar q2
profiles so i only have these areas
shown here uh but for most of these
trades we saw a very strong peak on 15 w
which suggested there might be some
relationship with sex so that was then
uh included as a co-variant so we could
actually pick out qtls on other
locations in the genome
interestingly when we um
did this for so they actually got a
secondary qtl on chromosome 7 which was
not expected at all and so we're really
interested in this focus as it might um
be playing a role in modishi and in fact
there is actually a pedal of three
um
gene in this
in this confidence interval which has
been shown to be involved in uh male 4
development and statement development in
arabidopsis
now for this area we have quite a few
qtls that uh pop up and for all the
other recommended traits as well and
many of these qtl have very promising
canon genes in them uh notably in
chromosome 16 there's a pin one homolog
and chromosome seventeen there's a
canadian homolog and these two genes
actually interact to specify the ad
axial and axiality identity and leaf
morphology
so that's the very promising um
kind of gene and there's also a few
other genes throughout these other
future involving leaf morphology and
development as well and then for stab we
found multiple uh photosystem genes and
thyrodoxin
genes uh in these confidence intervals
so now sort of in the next steps of the
study right we still have to do a few
more mapping studies using single plant
plots of the s2 family
notably uh instant resistance and rest
resistance since these are also pretty
high variability but we haven't had very
good insect or rust
incidents
uh the past couple years this spring we
planted an expanded genetics trial
including uh replicas of the sus2 family
and so
in the next few years we'll be able to
use that to do qgl mapping of much more
complex traits and you know slightly
lower heritable tricks that'll be very
interesting
especially since using only single time
plots we already saw qtl for high
variability traits
and then we're in the process of
resequencing a 9003 that militia's
parent and a select subset of the
progeny from each of those families so
we've plugged in pac bio data from from
9403 to parent we're in the process of
assembling that into a new a new genome
which we can then um
at that point we'll hopefully have a
malicious reference along with our male
and female references
and then we're doing the luminous
sequencing of some of the progeny which
will then map back to each of those
references which are the three different
parents in those families and that'll
hopefully help us narrow down in on the
actual lopes that's causal for monique
um and with that i'd like to thank the
current reform members of the smart lab
who contributed to this research as well
as our funding which has come from uh
over the years from the usd
as well as the nsf
and so with that i'll take any questions
if people have them
um
yeah so for this uh trait variation in
natural populations for monisi um
do you have a sense of
like is there an adaptive trade-off
going on in response to the environment
yeah so the question was with with
monique is there an adaptive trade-off
um in the environment going on so you
know
it's not that you know one of the
reasons
is um because
uh
you know there's a disadvantage for if
you're a male and daishi right a male
can't produce seeds right but it still
uses resources
um
so
so
for a foreign plant right um you know
we're not sure uh what exactly the
adaptive trade-off would be i mean an
advantage is right among them could
colonize a new area for example right it
only did especially because they didn't
sell fertile
um
you know again malaysia's willows are
pretty rare
but they are observed so
we're not highly sure um one thing
within terms of the variation of male
and female uh those two sites that we
saw hypersonic and janelle were
in the previous summer when flower set
actually occurs they were a lot drier
and warmer and that with other species
has been shown other malicious crops to
promote more male flowers so that that
could be one reason we saw more male
flowers in those other environments
yeah
um can you talk a little more about the
infidel that you mentioned on chromosome
15 i wonder how many genes the inda
covers or how long the endos and then
also in the qtl that you showed i didn't
see a peak for the indel is that because
you use snips or because like the
genetic analysis just didn't cover for
the phenotype right okay so yeah those
two questions so the first one was uh
can i tell you more about the indel um
on 15. so that indel is hypothetical um
i shouldn't clarify that so you know we
hypothesize that there's an
that's what we're hoping the savings and
information will actually confirm for us
right you know and again we're
hypothesizing that because from these
irrigation ratios it appears that 15 w
is responsible for monique it's
somewhere on that chromosome otherwise
you wouldn't be seeing these ratios the
way they are and you know furthermore
the fact that
we get 50 female in this
when we uh cross it to the reference
female instead of a third of each
right uh suggests that um
wwh is like a viable and if that weren't
the case that means something's going on
on wh to make it um lethal
and the most likely um scenario for that
would be a larger film right you know a
single staff might do that but probably
not
so that's why we're hypothesizing it's
an indel we don't know that yet but you
know
the siblings here look like you should
confirm that pretty easily you know
that'll appear
so the second question then was um about
the the qtl maps you know you don't see
a peak here at
the 15.
so there were peaks of 15 for all these
traits uh very strong peaks like log
scores like 15
right so that you know maybe other peaks
um when you have you know a strong peak
other qtls tend to not be called or
not shows high significance and so we i
included it as a covariate so we could
parse out this other iqto because the
chromosome 15 is uh
is characterized by a very strong
linkage just equilibrium so it's very
strongly linked so
um it's hard to parse out any specific
genes in there because everything is in
strong linkage
um so that's why we
mask that
but yes
uh the qtl for sex without
any covariance had a very very strong
peak
which of course we expect because that's
where sex is determined
any more questions
one other question um so you're
like it's i don't know much about
just plants or diacious um is that
normal that this is really just a single
locus like sex determination or could
there be another locus
yeah so the question was is it normal
that in malicious diocesan planets
there's a single locus that determines
sex yes that was known so this is a
binary trait right it's it's it's
it's not exactly mendelian but it you
know it's it's a binary in trade it's
not a quantitative trait so um
yes and in all examples of um
plants as far as i know there's only a
single
locus responsible for sex determination
and usually it's one or two genes right
so in some cases it's a single gene that
is a switch to a male and female and in
some cases it's two genes so one gene
that might um suppress the male and one
gene that might promote femaleness in a
cw system for example but
linked together such that they're never
um there's never any crossover between
them
all right well thank you well let's
thank brendan
[Applause]
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu